Founders have a dictatorized companies
take Mark Zuckerberg for example over
the past few years he's been gambling
tens of billions on the metaverse
something that investors haven't exactly
been excited about to make things worse
much of the launched metaverse products
have flopped beyond belief boasting as
little as just 38 users all of this has
given Zuckerberg a favorability rating
of just 22 this is precisely the type of
situation in which a CEO would be fired
but Mark doesn't have to worry about
that you see Mark only owns 13.6 percent
of meta not much more than Steve Jobs
take of 11 when he was fired so nowhere
near a majority but see modern Founders
haven't learned from their predecessors
they know what can happen if they give
away majority control while Zuckerberg
only owns 13 of meta he controls 54 of
its voting power